foreign
let's go to Molly
and San Diego what's up Molly
hi John what are you doing I'm just like
um well I'm talking to you for one made
my day because I'm freaking out because
I didn't think my question would be
answered oh don't freak out I'm not very
good at this
trust me we're good you're good you're
good what's up
um so yeah basically my question is how
do I kind of fix my marriage
I know we're just you're just talking
about that but like basically the way
you set that up was like I think you're
gonna ask my question it's not that big
a deal I thought you were gonna ask me
like I don't know what what I what shoes
I think are cool you're like how do I
fix my marriage all right help me out a
little bit uh dig in a little bit
Yeah so basically
um
I've been married for three years and
with my husband for about eight almost
nine and he's just frustrated and
you know we've been having a lot of
fights lately
and she's like I'm just sick and tired
of you
so like you gotta fix yourself I don't
know how but you know get therapy do
something and I'm like oh okay I would
say in the in the manual that I got
of things to not say when you're married
you need to fix yourself was was one of
those those lines
um okay so he's not he's not on the
phone with us and so all I can talk to
is you and so I don't want this call to
be all about him
tell me what's happening in your mirror
tell me what's happened in your marriage
the last three years
all right
we were pregnant and then now I have a
one-year-old baby girl so I know he's
stressed out but then he also kind of
made a side business during the pandemic
and he's also working a full-time job
it is expensive to live in San Diego
no question about it no question about
it but what does that have to do with
I'm sick of you you need to fix yourself
so basically our fights are very
repetitive and when we got together
um I gave him a list of what I want so
what I wanted was okay so did you just
hand them the Spice Girl lyrics like you
like you gave them a list of what I want
well it's incredible when
we were I guess courting we were you
know date to marry and that's what I
wanted I was like I'm looking for a
husband I'm being real I'm like I'm not
getting anything younger you're not
getting any younger so like is this for
real
and my list was basically like okay
you know my goal and this is you know I
was dreaming with him and I would say it
doesn't sound like you were dreaming
with him it sounds like you were telling
him what he was going to do to be a part
of your dream
he asked so I said okay I know I know I
know but this is gonna play I can
already tell it's gonna play this is
gonna play into
what I think your next steps are going
to be but I want you to own that this
was less about us dreaming about a
future together and this was more about
you handing them a list of the things
that you want and by the way this
relationship I'm already gonna tag it
with a ton of pressure because I'm
dating to marry I'm renting to own right
I am like I'm in this thing I will only
go out with you with an end in mind not
to get to know you not just to find out
who you are not to be you are a means to
a thing I'm gonna do
is that fair
yeah that's pretty fair and then you
handed him the list
just you should frame this list and put
it you hit him the list okay and so what
was on this list
so basically
um I just wanted like a partner that was
I guess beside me when I say beside me
is this
I wanted us to be like a power couple
constantly honor a game
um you know constantly getting better
improving ourselves and then also
staying in communication of like what we
wanted
and just
you know
how I always see you know successful
marriages I just wanted to be one of
those and that's what I told them and I
was like you know I want us to keep
dating I want us to constantly you know
be a positive couple for also like our
kids
because you know both of her parents are
divorced and we didn't want that so we
went to marriage counseling and our
passion has blessed us and
well we did two sessions of marriage
counseling because of communication is
one of my biggest areas so that's also
why he's also frustrated yeah you're not
good at it I can tell you right now
you're not good at it that's okay
there's things in my marriage that I'm
not good at and I've been doing this for
more than two decades right but
it sounds like you gave him a job
description
of this is the way things were going to
be and if you go back and I want you to
listen to the things you said by the way
you have to I'm going to ask you to do
something and you have to promise me
you'll do it you promise
yeah do not read the YouTube comments on
this okay cool
oh yeah I know I know okay good social
media okay so listen I believe with all
my heart that you are coming at this
with the best of intentions
you live through hell as a kid he did
too yeah and you have come to a place
where that will not happen again and the
way it won't happen again is I'm going
to control every variable moving forward
correct
yeah yeah and so I bet you're a joy
first time new mom too right incredible
and so I'm gonna control every variable
because I will not get hurt again
and so you end up hiring a husband
you don't roll over and look at somebody
in the eye and say I love you so much
and I'm giving you access to my soul and
that means you can hurt me worse than I
was hurt as a kid and I'm asking you not
to do that let's build something
together
that goes against every fiber of your
being for good measure
because that happened to me when you
were a kid because all kids are is
they're just walking exposed vulnerable
little creatures and so they absorb
their parents hatred for one another and
their fights and their frustration and
all the drama
and so it makes perfect sense
so I'm not I'm I'm sitting here with you
I totally get it
but I'm hearing the other side of this
which is I don't want to work here
anymore
yeah that's what I'm getting to and if I
look at what just what you're describing
it sounds like you have a husband that
is working his butt off to create a
vision to to help create the vision for
your life
and if you go back and listen to the way
you laid it out want to be a power
couple a couple that's always doing this
that's always
there's nothing about a couple who
abides in one another
I rest
I can I can anchor off the side of this
thing because I'm so anchored into you
and vice versa
and instead of saying here's a list of
what I want my demand list here's what I
need and those are asking somebody for
their needs is an invitation
asking someone to do what you want
that's a totally different proposition
you know what I'm saying yeah I hear you
my boss tells me what I will do
my wife asked me hey here's what I need
we'd be a part of this
and one of those is exhausting you've
worked for bosses like that it's
exhausting I wanted it like this I
wanted it like this this is our company
we're gonna do this we're gonna make
this much money it's just like all right
dude all right cool
let me break
yeah that sounds about right does that
make sense
yeah he's just frustrated because I
didn't meet that expectation that I said
no it's not always frustrating it's
frustrating because he loves you and you
won't let him in
oh okay he's frustrated because as soon
as he starts moving close you push his
buttons so hard
and you will nag and complain him to
death right Am I Wrong tell me if I'm
wrong
but just fight I don't negative
surprisingly I don't nag okay so you
might not nag but that it could be worse
because nagging is just little bitty
drops
right like I'm just I'm just sprinkling
every minute of every day that'll kill
somebody but so will just letting it all
build up until you blast them with a
fire hose the water amount is the same
that's true oh okay okay listen to me
carefully the issues that y'all are
dealing with are not the problem okay
the issues are setting off automated
responses that have been guiding your
life for years
you will not get the marriage you want
by controlling every variable you will
get the marriage you want by completely
letting go and say I love you till the
end of time will you love me back
mm-hmm
and sitting down together and saying hey
let's build this thing that we want
because he might not want to be a power
couple he might just want to love his
wife like crazy and go for walks in the
neighborhood
he may not have a vested interest in
being the couple that everyone looks to
you may just want to love the crap out
of his wife and his kids
which of course over time makes you the
couple that people look up to
oh oh
yeah
I can see that you see what I'm saying
yeah and I understand listen to me what
I'm asking you to do is going to be the
most terrifying thing you've ever done
it's gonna be scarier than having a kid
because you already had that mapped out
and planned out and blogged out and you
listen all the podcasts and you got the
books you were ready to rock and roll
what I don't believe that first I don't
listen
the issues will keep coming up and by
the way if you leave this relationship
or he leaves this relationship these are
going to show up in your next
relationship are going to show up in the
one after that
mm-hmm
because you have you've married your
unfinished business
oh you're gonna have to let go your
body's still trying to ask what was so
bad about you that Mom and Dad split up
and you're gonna show the world how
freaking perfect you are
and you're not he's not either and
that's what makes it the whole thing
incredible
I see okay
like I'm just you know with marriage
counseling
our passions were just like you know set
Whoever has the highest standard go with
that yeah that's it's stupid it's dumb
okay dumb
it's like marriage is not a high jump
competition
it's so dumb it's terrible advice
and if one of your pastors wants to call
me I'll tell them that to their terrible
advice she was at the higher standard
and you meet that standard then you
raise that standard dude you are that's
you're setting your marriage up for
competition
yeah and it's a one loss proposition and
that is not how successful marriages
work
no successful marriages open their eyes
every morning and they look at that
weird nose hair and those weird
breathing noises and God what happened
to your eyebrow like all that
and say I love you because I choose to
and I'm gonna be about helping you meet
your needs today
that's how it works
I would love for you to take your
husband out and say the what I've been
trying to accomplish isn't working
and I'm sorry
and by the way I know he's not perfect
he's just not on the phone with me okay
hopefully he pitches in on his part okay
but you gotta be willing to go forward
if you can't qualify and be like and you
know you've been you can't do that don't
do that because he's got he's got to
fight you he's got his Wall's got to
come back up
yeah
tell him sorry
and tell him I want you to take my wants
list and I'm gonna throw that thing away
and start over
what world do we want to create together
together
what do you want this to feel like what
do we want this to look like what do we
want this our experiences to be
how can I best love you
and not here's what I want but here's
how you can best love me but let him go
first
I think I I I I I I think your marriage
is going to be great
and him stop trying to compete for
whatever some gold star
and be about loving each other
and be about a shared vision of What Not
the next 40 years are going to look like
you don't know what's coming in 40 years
let's get through six months
what do we want the next six months to
feel like to look like how can we do
that
let's start there and let's do this
again in six months let's do this again
after that
let's keep building and rebuilding and
building and rebuilding and building and
rebuilding and let's do it together
that my friend is marriage